I still remember the day I first created
my facebook profile I was 13 years old
8th grade and my friend Lauren told me
to make one I was still pretty happy
with my space back when I was still the
cool thing to do but she said tile this
social media site is so cool that it's
only for college students but we should
use it too so i did my first post was a
picture of me and my friends taking a
selfie with the photobooth app in a
macbook with a macbook in the apple
store in the shopping mall because well
that was the cool thing to do with your
friends of course this was normal for me
a teenage kid growing up in Silicon
Valley where Google and Facebook and
other huge tech companies were right in
my backyard going to Stanford only
increase my exposure to technology
creating your own startup and trying to
be the next Mark Zuckerberg was so
popular that I would see jokes on campus
with saying oh my gosh don't start a
start-up we're saving you from yourself
okay don't do it now most people assume
that since I went to Stanford it and I
want to be a filmmaker that I study film
there I actually studied Spanish random
I know and an interdisciplinary major
called science technology and society
with a concentration in information
media I know it's a bit of a mouthful my
sisters who majored in traditional
fields such as medicine and engineering
like to joke that I pretty much majored
in social media to be fair I think they
thought that because our thinking notes
in our graduation program were a maximum
140 characters but I was still a little
insulted little did I realize that my
courses in digital communication
photography coding and more would be so
relevant to the current landscape in a
film industry and also to how my friends
and I keep in touch the waves my friends
and I communicate now have evolved from
phone calls and text messages to visuals
such as photos and videos just by
scrolling through my Instagram and
Twitter I can see not only what my
friends are up to but also celebrities
like Beyonce Michelle Obama my friends
can send me gifs and memes through I
message and group me when I travel I'd
love to make snapchat videos so that my
friends and people all over the world
can see what I'm up to you in real time
no actually let's make one right now
yeah this is happening okay yeah okay
I'm going to San
chat video okay yes this is happening
whoo everyone say hi oh yeah this is a
live snapchat video mm-hmm this is real
this is not a stunt yes whoa okay I'm
done okay oh I'm gonna get a lot of
views oh thanks guys the ways that we
communicate how is translated to how we
consume content with hdmi cables and
chromecast's and other wireless
connections to our screens our phones
and our tablets become the remote
because we have all this technology we
can consume and access content whenever
and however we want to so I decided to
make a short film about how technology
is changing the way we communicate now
hope you enjoy
it's amazing that something so small can
change how we tell stories
a pixel when you put thousands of them
together the sky's the limit because of
these pixels these tiny pieces of bits
and bytes we can capture life's moments
relive them in the palm of our hands and
share them with the world but is a movie
still a movie with this screen what
about this one or that one course it is
this is the brave new world of
storytelling the new frontier you may
not be able to predict the future we can
always embrace it so whatever comes
whatever happens I'm excited to tell my
stories and be a part of this new wave
of storytelling
so most of that film like the end hahaha
was shot in Barcelona where last month I
had the pleasure of participating in
landscape film festival a film festival
collaboration where me and 100
filmmakers were split up into ten teams
to make a short film in two weeks and it
was a fantastic experience our team was
from all over the world London Spain
Venezuela and more I learned so much
about the filmmaking process and just by
watching my teammates in action and let
me tell you nothing will improve your
spanish more than working on a
spanish-speaking set but what was so
striking about working with this team of
filmmakers is that we were all digital
native filmmakers now who exactly is a
digital native filmmaker in my opinion
it's anyone who wants to make films and
was introduced to filmmaking primarily
into digital medium one of the biggest
advantage is a digital native filmmaker
like me has his resources today it's
more accessible than ever to learn the
craft of filmmaking with YouTube videos
and blogs like no film school and
articles and forums and more there's
just no excuses to just go out and
Google what you need to know in january
i took an online film course hosted by
the national film and television school
one of the top film schools in the UK
over the course of six weeks i learned
about the whole process of filmmaking
through video lectures and short film
case studies all for the grand total of
zero dollars also equipment is much
cheaper thus opening the filmmaking
space to be more open and democratic the
fact that our team can make such a high
quality short film within such a short
time frame with the equipment we already
had at our disposal is really
astonishing it shows how accessible and
low-cost filmmaking is now another
example that short film you saw earlier
was shot and edited entirely on my iPad
now that was a first for me usually i
used my DSLR my laptop but my laptop was
broken so I to be a little more
inventive and I felt like a huge tourist
just like walking around with an iPad
like this all day but I think it was
worth it the fact I can make a short
film with some taps on my screen and
upload it directly to YouTube and Vimeo
is really remarkable because of these
tools and platforms filmmakers like me
can create
content upload it and find an audience
right now there's a huge trend to
filmmakers creating their own web series
some of them have been picked up by TV
networks while others are funded via
crowdfunding or available for purchase
via on demand in Barcelona I wrote shot
and edited a comedic web series about
students studying abroad in Barcelona
although we didn't finish a whole season
we just made two episodes in some promo
videos it's amazing that with just a
camera my laptop and some phones to
record the audio I can have my own show
now creating your own show and creating
content is still difficult you need to
organize and find collaborators and
other actors and artists to work with
you and support yourself but right now
there are less excuses to just go out
create and tell our stories right now
I'm writing a feat screenplay for a
feature film they plan on shooting for a
very small budget it's called 501 miles
and it's about two strains childhood
friends who go on a road trip after
college graduation from San Francisco to
San Diego and the fact that you even
even fathom shooting a film for so
little money shows how technology is
empowering storytellers to tell our own
stories as a filmmaker I want to tell
stories where characters are trying to
figure out their identity to figure out
what they want in life for figure out
what kind of person they want to be in
501 miles the two girls are trying to
decide what are they to go the path
expected of them or whether they should
follow their passions which is a lot
more risky as someone who grew up
practically our whole teenage and adult
life with social media I'm 22 now so in
10 18 when 23 will be 10 years a decade
with social media I know firsthand how
hard it is to establish a strong sense
of self seeing your Facebook friends and
their accomplishments like new jobs and
acceptances into prestigious grad
schools and in relationship milestones
on Instagram and Twitter all this
information about our friends or our
peers makes us wonder if we measure up
it makes us feel like life is a contest
that feeling that's something that
brings a whole level of insecurity that
our grandparents and our parents never
had to deal with before
by sharing the parts of ourselves we
only want to share with others we really
have to think about how we grapple with
that sense of identity and insecurity
that comes along with it and it really
affects how we view ourselves in the
eyes of others I also want to tell
stories where characters are forced to
confront their preconceived notions
about people in the world around them
their biases I especially resonate with
stories about characters or trying to
figure out who they are as a person
while the outside world tries to label
them based on how they look in the film
I'm writing the two girls come from two
different backgrounds one is
nigerian-american who is trying to
figure out her expectations especially
as the child of immigrants the other is
white privilege and has a happy-go-lucky
attitude about life yet she grapples
with her sexual identity and doesn't
quite know how to deal with romantic
relationships especially after college
and because of social media we can
figure out who we are and in during this
trip they're trying to figure out why
they justed apart in the first place
they have to come to terms with the
racial and cultural tensions that caused
them to drift apart as a filmmaker but
especially as an african-american woman
is my priority to tell stories with
strong and nuanced female characters and
people of color but also diverse in
sexual identity ability and more
especially because they are very
underrepresented in films today I
believe that these films are important
to make and I want to make sure I tell
these stories authentically and not as a
stereotype because of social media
people are empowered to tell their
stories about their experiences of
mistreatment racism and sexism away from
media speculation and distortion by
seeing these accounts firsthand from
recent news breaking events such as the
recent conflict in Baltimore sexual
assault on college campuses and more
people who may have only had access to
one side of the story can now see the
issues and discussions from other points
of view because of social media because
everyone can be a storyteller stories
that may have been silenced or passed
over now have a chance to be seen and
heard not just because
there is a platform there's a way to
make your voice heard it doesn't mean
you're always being listened to for
every enlightening article about the
reality of race relations and gender
discrimination there is an ignorant
response or racist tweet right back but
at the very least there's a space to
create a dialogue and listen to other
perspectives should people choose to so
as empowered as I am and excited as I am
to write this feature and shoot it how
will I find an audience you know because
with all the social media going on it's
really interesting to see what's going
on in social media today as empowered as
an to write this film and shoot it how
will I find an audience we all know that
people are going to movie theaters less
now we people are going to see their
movies on their tablets and screens but
one of the biggest reasons I want to
become a filmmaker was the feeling of
showing a film to an audience that
wonderful feeling of just showing that
having everyone see what you've made
like I really look up to filmmakers like
Ava Duvernay and alfonso cuarón I'm FAO
kassovitz who use films to engage and
inspire and really shed light on issues
today I also really look up to directors
whose movies are really entertaining a
visually visually appealing like
Christopher Nolan and Steven Spielberg I
still remember the first time I saw the
prestige when I was 14 and the ending
just blew my mind I was like oh my god
this is so cool and I watched that movie
so many times and what's amazing about
these filmmakers is that they made their
first films with costly and bulky
equipment whereas filmmakers like me are
making our first films with dslrs
camcorders and sometimes our iphones and
tablets so as excited as I am about how
these digital tools are making the
barrier of entry point for filmmakers
much easier because of that why well I
just don't have that same feeling of
gratification when I share my films
digitally like two years ago
when I had a documentary that I shot and
edited in London about the Nigerian
community there I had a very small
screen is just mostly me and my friends
and my family and some members of the
public but I still remember that feeling
of everyone watching something that I
made and that's something that I
wouldn't have had if I just sent the
link out on an email or post it in on
youtube so yes I'm making this feature
and I'm shooting it but how will I find
an audience so and everyone has digital
communication mediums now to just watch
films I need to really think about ways
to find an audience and engage with them
how can I do that at the end of the day
if we filmmakers want people to come to
the theater and see our movies on the
big screen we have to be more inventive
and entrepreneurial we have to think out
of the box and think about not only how
to get our film scene but also how to
capitalize on this digital space to fund
our art and our future career today is
more important than ever to add more
value to a movie ticket especially for
smaller independent movies also it's way
more important to make movie going more
communal for example there are some
movies that have live performance
screenings where musicians can play the
sound track alongside the movie just
like the old days where the orchestra's
would play the film score alongside the
movies for one summer I saw beasts of
the southern wild where the director and
his band played the entire soundtrack of
the film and for a huge audience in an
outdoor theater in Brooklyn and it
remains as one of my favorite movie
going experiences and I it was really
incredible but what does that mean for
me as a filmmaker like how can I pull
this off in the future well there even
be cinemas anymore like in the future
and will people just will my future
generation and people in my age group
and younger will they just be lazy and
just watch films on their screens and
tablets and movie theaters will
disappear may
really hope not but in my opinion as a
filmmaker and as a consumer there is
nothing like showing your movie and to
an audience or watching a movie in a
theater I think it's important to have a
healthy balance of both the
romanticization and the progressiveness
of filmmaking today on the one hand we
have movie theaters and established
recognition in the industry such as the
Oscars and prestigious film festivals
but on the other hand it's really
important to embrace future models and
venues for the medium yet however we
consume content there will always be a
need for storytellers storytellers like
me and that's something technology can't
replace thank you